[Music]
imagine for a moment that you are one of
the great Emperors of ancient China
perhaps the very first emperor Qin Shi
Huangdi or the great martial emperor of
the Han Dynasty Rudy or even emperor
xuanzong of the awesome Tang Dynasty
if you were the great emperor xuanzong
then this would be the Year 740 of the
Common Era and you would be ruling the
vast Tung Chinese Empire from your
magnificent palace in the heart of
Chang'an undoubtedly the most splendid
capital city on earth your city is 30
square miles an area home to 2 million
people including tens of thousands of
foreigners from all over Asia by way of
comparison London and Paris would have
had populations of less than 50,000
people each during this same period and
your court is resplendent with beautiful
concubines with some of the finest poets
and musicians who ever lived and even a
troupe of dancing horses in the vast
agricultural regions of China
surrounding the capital dwell untold
millions of peasant farmers who have
created the most successful commercial
farming system the world has ever seen
great camel caravans are constantly
leaving your city carrying bales of raw
silk destined for markets in the
enormous realm of Islam and merchants
from all over Eurasia are flocking back
into Chang'an bringing with them their
languages their foods their music and
their religions this is one of the great
moments in world history a moment when
China was undoubtedly the wealthiest and
most powerful entity the world had ever
seen
and this journey upon which we are
embarking together will take you to the
very heart of the extraordinary
achievements of Chinese and Eastern
civilization we have sown
to explore so many fascinating people
and ideas to encounter so many
historical and cultural threads to
follow as we tease out the core elements
of eastern civilization and consider
their role in the making of the modern
world together we will discover the big
ideas of Eastern civilization we see
firsthand how these ideas were created
and by whom had they developed and were
changed over time and how they
eventually spread from their center of
origin to engulf the entire eastern
hemisphere we learn how these ideas were
expressed in art in architecture in
great works of literature and philosophy
and in the religious ideologies customs
and aesthetics that made the nations of
East Asia so distinctly well Eastern
some of these big ideas and the material
entities they produced are things you
most likely already know something about
I'm thinking of course of iconic
structures like the Great Wall of China
which stretches 5,500 miles along the
northern borders as a permanent reminder
of the the struggles that took place in
these frontier regions where so many
Chinese dynasties were forced to defend
themselves against the nomadic horseback
warriors of the steppes like the Shah
knew and the mighty Mongols it was the
first emperor of China himself who
ordered the walls be constructed a
massive undertaking that costs the lives
of tens of thousands of conscripted
workers we visit the Forbidden City that
huge complex of residences temples and
gardens hidden behind its own protective
walls closed off even from its own
people the city was so isolated that the
last emperor of the Ming Dynasty had no
idea that rebels were about to take the
capital of Beijing virtually until the
moment he saw them climbing over the
walls of the city traumatized he killed
his family with his own sword and then
hanged himself from a pagoda tree deep
inside the Forbidden City we will also
join Chinese archaeologists as they
began to unearth the thousands of
extraordinary life-sized terracotta
soldiers in order to learn what the
first Emperor
chyna hope to achieve in the afterlife
with this army frozen in time although
you might already know a little about
these iconic structures will dig deeper
to see how these achievements reflect
much more ancient cultural and
ideological currents the great themes of
Eastern civilization and how these
monuments continue to reflect the
powerful foundational principles that
resonate in the region even today in
addition will encounter some
lesser-known but equally important
people our places and events will meet
First Minister you of that shock dynasty
who 4,000 years ago labored mightily to
bend the flow of the Yangtze River will
explore the practice of human sacrifice
carried out by the Shang Dynasty Kings
and we'll walk through devastated
warring States China with great
philosophers like Confucius as they
sought solutions to centuries of civil
war together we traveled the Silk Roads
writing the extraordinary Bactrian
camels carrying gorgeous Chinese silk
that will eventually be worn by the
fabulously wealthy patrician women of
Rome and we see that even as Chinese
silk was flowing out of China and on to
Rome at a cost by the way of perhaps six
million Roman gold coins every year
no wonder the Chinese border guards to
search the caravans to make sure no one
was carrying silkworms out of China and
jeopardizing the Chinese monopoly but
even as this fabulously expensive silk
was leaving the great Indian spiritual
philosophy of Buddhism was using the
same trade routes to spread eastwards
into China
then on to Korea Japan and Vietnam to
profoundly influenced the evolution of
culture in those countries we also
explore the rich culture of Korea under
its array of glittering dynasties and
the story of Japanese culture as it
passed through stages from Chinese
influenced opulence to samurai dominated
feudalism and then on to modernization
and eventually imperialism this is also
a course about people including peasants
like Hong Wu who founded the Ming
Dynasty one of only three peasants who
ever ruled China about
artisans who created the Magnificent
Buddhist temples of ancient korea and
japan about the awesomely powerful
emperors and the extraordinary women of
east asia who are all collectively woven
into the rich fabric of eastern
civilization we follow the story of
Eastern civilization from its origins
and one of the great cradles of all
human civilization through its evolution
into a vast and complex cultural Empire
which created its own unique solutions
to the problems of sustaining vast
populations in orderly productive
societies what you quickly come to
realize is that all of us have been
lifelong students of Eastern
civilization without perhaps even being
aware of it I say this because so much
of what we explore in this course has
also shaped our world in the West so
gaining insight into these developments
is it's not only essential to
understanding why the East is what it is
today but also why the interconnected
global world of the 21st century is the
way it is today we will spend a lot of
time exploring the traditions of China
almost half of our time in fact China
plays a major role in our story because
this is where many of the foundational
ideas of Eastern civilization first
emerged China is the very cradle of
Eastern civilization but China is not
the whole story of Eastern civilization
will travel far beyond its borders we
explore the the spread of these Chinese
ideas into other regions of the eastern
hemisphere into Korea and Japan and into
Vietnam and Cambodia
even Tibet and Central Asia and at the
same time we also consider the impact of
cultural products that spread into East
Asia from other far-flung places I'm
thinking of technologies like
sophisticated glassblowing and new
musical instruments from the
Mediterranean and Central Asia or foods
like the peanut and corn from the
Americas and of course great religions
like Buddhism from India menarchy ism
from Central Asia Islam from Arabia and
Christianity from the Mediterranean all
of which influenced and modified Eastern
civil
in so many fascinating ways these
imports blended with the ancient
philosophies foods and technologies of
the East to create an extraordinary
syncretic mix which has been enriching
our world for millennia this then is the
exciting mission we are embarking upon
but to get properly started I think we
need to do something very tricky first
and that is to try and define what we
mean by the three key words in the title
of this course foundations Eastern and
civilization each of these words is
laden with context and hidden layers of
meaning and each word can be
surprisingly controversial in its own
way what does the word Eastern mean to
you for example how would you define the
meaning of the word civilization it is a
widely used word but still there is
considerable disagreement about its
meaning and even as common a word as
foundations can have multiple meanings
take a look in any dictionary and you'll
see what I mean so this is the task that
will occupy us now for most of the
remainder of this first lecture a search
for an understanding of the meaning of
foundations of Eastern and of
civilization the very words we have
chosen to describe our course let's
start with the word Eastern what do we
mean when we speak of Eastern in the
context of this course now in popular
culture today Eastern essentially means
anything to do with Asia that is
virtually the entire Asian continent
from the Middle East through to the
Pacific Ocean from the steppes of
Siberia to the very bottom of the Indian
subcontinent it is often used in
contrast to the term Western which
usually denotes Europe and the Americas
this definition of Eastern is frankly
far too broad to be useful here and it
also misses some fundamental
distinctions and subtleties so let's try
and be more specific about the scope of
our course in this course we are
defining Eastern to mean the culture and
history of China Korea Japan and the
nations of Southeast Asia
in focusing solely on this region we are
obviously leaving out other important
regions that have traditionally been
defined as belonging to the eastern
hemisphere most obviously the vast
Indian subcontinent
but although defining Eastern in this
way might seem a little controversial we
have some very powerful reasons for
doing so that I think will help us
understand more precisely what Eastern
civilization actually is what makes this
specific region so distinct then and why
should these countries in particular be
the focus for our exploration of the
foundations of Eastern civilization
the reason is China we focus on those
regions of the world that have been
profoundly influenced over thousands of
years by the foundational cultural
achievements of the Chinese as we will
see despite the many fascinating and
powerful connections that we'll trace
with so many other parts of the world
the region that includes China Korea
Japan and Southeast Asia collectively
constitutes its own distinct and
extraordinary solar system if you like
with China as the Sun China has been the
great cultural giant of the East and all
the other states of the region have
found themselves caught up in its
gravitational pull like so many planets
orbiting a powerful star it's precisely
because of this gravitational pull that
it is reasonable to speak of an eastern
hemisphere joined by common cultural
ideas practices and customs that have
United the entire region throughout
history down to the present day
but let me immediately clarify that I'm
not suggesting the other states of East
Asia were just carbon copies of China
far from it despite the size the power
and the wealth of China we in fact see
many ways in which people in Korea Japan
and Vietnam all managed to resist being
swamped by the Chinese cultural tidal
wave and developed their own unique
ideas and customs it is actually in this
complex interchange of Chinese and
indigenous ideas in the great cities and
temples of Korea
Japan and Vietnam that the foundations
of Eastern civilization have endured and
evolved for this reason we explore the
glorious boo gooks a Buddhist temple of
Korea with its massive Buddha and
gigantic bronze bells a complex so
extraordinary it has been designated as
historic and scenic site number 1 by the
South Korean government we enter the
sophisticated high an era of Japan a
sumptuous world of gloriously dressed
men who would exotic mysterious women by
mixing perfumes and admiring their
calligraphy even as the peasants were
leading miserable lives in the real
world beyond the super refined chord and
we will visit the Magnificent temples of
Angkor Wat in Cambodia product of
indigenous camus construction but also
of Chinese Buddhist and Indian Hindu
cultural influences a unesco world
heritage site that stands today as a
testament to the syncretic diversity of
Eastern civilization but even with all
these diverse cultural influences at
play the vibrant creative energy of
China is the primary thread that we
follow china wills the same degree of
influence on Eastern civilization that
the Greeks and Romans wield on Western
civilization so we have two ways of
defining Eastern in this course
geographically but also culturally and
we do acknowledge that both these
definitions can be controversial let's
move on to the word civilization which
frankly is an even more difficult
concept to define than Eastern the word
civilization comes from a latin root
sieve and upon this route several other
words can be constructed civis for
example means citizen Civitas is the
latin word for a city or a city state
and Sevilla's can mean civil polite or
citizen like the common element here
obviously is the city and its citizens
so strictly speaking when we use the
word civilization we are describing
regions of the world in which cities are
the largest and most important
communities
according to this definition the word
civilization should only strictly be
used to refer to states that emerged
after cities had appeared on the planet
for the very first time these first
cities emerge roughly 5,000 years ago in
the Delta regions of the Tigris and
Euphrates rivers in a place then called
Sumeria a part of modern-day Iraq these
first cities you know the MER earth rook
and Babylon were followed by cities in
Egypt and then in the Indus Valley in
Central Asia in China certainly the
Mediterranean other parts of Africa and
much later in the Americas the
appearance of cities and the states and
civilizations they came to dominate
marks the beginning of a new era in
human history which big historians with
their very wide perspective on history
have labeled the era of agrarian
civilizations we add the word agrarian
here as a reminder that despite the size
and complexity of the cities in their
urban life ways most people still farm
for a living
just like today the millions of humans
living in these cities were utterly
dependent on successful farming the
appearance of cities States and these
agrarian civilizations did not mean by
the way that all other types of human
communities suddenly disappeared now
even as great agrarian civilizations
spread across Eurasia millions of humans
continue to survivers hunter-gatherers
or small-scale subsistence farmers or as
pastoral nomads and here is where we
encounter some of the controversy
surrounding the word civilization in the
classical sense of the word civilized is
often used to compare and contrast one
type of community or life way the so
called civilized community with peoples
that might follow a very different life
way nomadism for example that is often
termed uncivilized so another example
the Romans were civilized the Huns were
uncivilized that
the word civilized is often used as a
value judgment to argue that Roman
attitudes Roman life ways and
achievements were superior to Hunnish
attitudes life ways and achievements now
this is the main reason that modern
historians often prefer to avoid the
word civilization altogether because it
has been used for so long - to pass
judgment on the success or cultural
superiority of a particular society I
can assure you that we will be very
careful not to pass judgment on nomadic
life ways in this course but we will
also acknowledge that the great cities
and agrarian civilizations of Eurasia
quickly became the most dynamic human
communities of all we should also
quickly mention perhaps some of the
defining characteristics that were
common to all agrarian civilizations
wherever they appeared in the world in
the world all these civilizations were
controlled by States which we can define
as political structures that wield power
based on coercion these states all
supported themselves through the
collection of tributes that is they use
their military muscle to extract
resources from the citizenry by the
threat of force agrarian civilizations
are also characterized by a complex
division of labor will see the myriad
numbers of ways that humans made their
livings in these great cities for
example they're also characterized by
writing and by bureaucracies to
administer these huge populations and
also for the first time in human history
by very steep hierarchies of wealth
gender power and ethnicity the fact is
once these communities appeared it
became possible to amass great wealth
and great power and now once wealth but
also one's gender and one's ethnicity
began to matter for the first time in
human history in determining the place
that you occupied in these newly
constructed social hierarchies the
development of these hierarchies of the
interrelationship between peasants and
elites for example and the ever changing
status of women will be one of the key
foundational themes of Eastern
civilization
that guides us one of the extraordinary
women that we'll meet is yang GUI Fei of
the Tang Dynasty who left her husband to
the Emperor's own son to become
concubine of the great emperor xuanzong
himself later yang GUI Fei got caught up
in a a dangerous rebellion against the
tongue against the Emperor and the old
Emperor who deeply loved her could only
watch her hang he was so distressed that
he abdicated soon after and spent the
rest of his life lamenting her loss
so these defining political economic
social and gender characteristics are
common to almost all civilizations
around the world of course but the story
that these lectures will unfold is that
of Eastern civilization in particular as
we set out to answer these key questions
what made each turn civilization unique
how can we distinguish Eastern
civilization from all the other
civilizations in Mesopotamia in Africa
in the Americas upon what particular
foundations did the the big ideas of
Eastern civilization stand as they
answer the pressing questions facing
their own societies and how did these
foundational ideas endure and evolve to
help shape the world we live in today
these questions bring me to the final
word in the title of the series that we
need to consider foundations what can we
say about the many of the word
foundations as you'll see if you look it
up in the dictionary foundations is a
surprisingly complex word with many
meanings several of which I think can be
applied to this course a foundation can
be a a basis like a principal an axiom
an idea upon which something stands or
is supported so we can talk about the
foundational principles of mathematics
or physics of engineering it can be the
solid base or support of something
tangible like the foundations of a
building and it can also be applied more
broadly to human communities and life
ways we can talk about the foundations
of modern society for example
in the context of this course this last
and most reassuringly vague meaning is
probably closest to what we are trying
to do but it will be useful to keep all
of these definitions in mind as we go
through the next 47 lectures our goal in
these lectures is no less ambitious than
to identify define and trace the
development of all these significant
cultural ideas and principles that
emerged inside this concept that we have
defined as Eastern civilization and then
to see how these core foundational ideas
endured and went on to influence the
development of society and civilization
both within the Eastern cultural realm
but also right around the world I have
mentioned some of these foundational
elements already these key themes ideas
about government about economic
organization social relationships gender
relationships ideas about religion
philosophy other ideologies ideas about
writing technology visual and literary
art and so on we explore these core
foundational elements of Eastern
civilization across vast areas of
geographical space and eons of
historical time let me try and highlight
some of the things we'll be looking at
as we explore these foundational
principles listen for these reoccurring
along the way one essential element that
we will be talking about at the
beginning of each region is the
geography climate and ecology of that
region because people's and their ideas
are powerfully shaped by nature as we
enter China Korea Japan and Southeast
Asia we explore how the rivers the
mountains the deserts and the natural
resources shaped the peoples who settle
there and the societies they created I'm
talking about wild desert frontiers like
the Gobi like the highest mountain
ranges on earth the Himalaya flooding
rivers like the Yangtze and the Yellow
River earthquakes along the great
tectonic fault zones of Japan oceans
that were so terrifying to the Mongols
that the rulers of the Koyo dynasty in
Korea simply relocated
they're caught to an island just off the
coast knowing that the Mongols would
never dare cross the Straits and attack
them we explore the fierce typhoons that
devastated the coast of East Asia we
explore the volcanoes like sacred
mountain bite do in North Korea
legendary birthplace of former North
Korean ruler Kim Jong Il all these have
played a critical role in shaping
behavior and ideas after establishing
our environmental context our stage if
you like we look at early human
migrations into East Asia and the Stone
Age life ways and beliefs that sustained
these migrants we look at the first
dwellings from the small communal huts
that common people lived worked prayed
and died for to the architecture of the
great cities they evolved into cities
like Chang'an modern Xian in China
arguably the greatest Imperial city on
earth for thousands of years we enter
the temples and monasteries built for
the religions of Eastern civilization
built for taoism buddhism Shintoism and
we see how these great faiths competed
for the hearts and souls of the untold
millions of humans who have dwelt within
the eastern hemisphere we explore some
of the richest schools and ideas of
philosophy ever devised by humans
particularly Confucianism whose
influence on Eastern civilization has
been just as profound as the influence
of Plato and Aristotle on the West
together we consider some of the
greatest works of Eastern literature
great novels like Journey to the West
Romance of the Three Kingdoms The Tale
of Genji
the superb poetry from the Golden Age of
Chinese poetry during the Tang Dynasty
along with very poignant poems from the
Silla dynasty in korea and the high-end
court in japan and let's not forget the
extraordinary technological inventions
of Eastern civilization printing steel
the compass gunpowder even the
wheelbarrow it at its heart our journey
is about the people we meet along the
way we meet great rulers
the first emperor of China who died
after drinking an elixir of mercury in
his search for eternal life we meet
Madhu the great ruler of the Xiong nu
nomads who killed his own father and
then constructed an awesome force of 300
thousand mounted Archer warriors that
absolutely terrified the Chinese we meet
King Sejong of the Korean Chosun dynasty
who is responsible for creating the the
Korean writing system Hangul we also
meet the great Mongol leaders Chinggis
Khaan and his grandson Kublai Khan who
founded the powerful yuan dynasty in
China this was the Emperor that Marco
Polo met on his extraordinary travels
and we meet more modern leaders like a
Emperor Meiji who transformed Japan from
a backward feudal state to one of the
great powers of the world in just two
generations and of course we also meet
Mao Zedong the revolutionary leader who
founded the People's Republic of China
one of the most iconic figures of the
20th century and again we meet exotic
and brilliant women like Ben jowl who
created the very notion of the ideal
Confucian woman like the ancient
Japanese shaman Queen Himiko and like
empress wu Zeitung still to this day the
only woman ever to rule china and this
is a course about the lives the hopes
the aspirations of the common people the
merchants who rode their camels along
the Silk Roads the peasants who grew the
food to sustain the largest populations
ever seen in human history and the
slaves who built the tombs the monuments
and the great walls of East Asia
collectively it is these extraordinary
men and women whose lives and
achievements have woven the rich
tapestry of Eastern civilization this is
a story of triumph and tragedy without
parallel in the history of the world and
it's my great pleasure and very good
fortune to unfold it for you
[Music]
[Music]
you